Себастіан Гульде зі Штутгарта очолює
один з патрулів спеціальної моніторингової місії ОБСЄ на Донбасі,
оловна функція якої - моніторинг дотримання режиму тиші.
Порушення міжнародні спостерігачі фіксують майже щодня,
як-от цього разу поблизу пункту пропуску Майорськ.
"Яка ситуація з безпекою за добу?"
"Вночі був трохи обстріл, зі стрілецької зброї."
До виконання обов’язків спостерігача
37-ми-річний Себастіан підходить з німецькою ретельністю.
Він з’ясовує , чи не виникають у місцевих жителів
проблеми з проходженням через пункти пропуску
з обох сторін лінії розмежування.
Чи є проблеми з опаленням, водопостачанням, продуктами харчування.
Моніторить перебіг ремонтних робіт
на електоремережах чи газогонах біля лінії фронту.
Крім того, йому та його колегам доводиться
фіксувати та повідомляти про випадки загибелі
мирних жителів, відвідуючи місце трагедії або морги.
"Бачиш людей, які просто хотіли жити,
але були в такий жорстокий спосіб
просто вирвані з життя.
Ми фіксували також інциденти,
коли діти гралися з снарядами,  що не розірвалися,
з амуніцією, залишеною військовими,
яка зрештою вибухала.
Це ті випадки, яких я ніколи не зможу забути".
Себасітан працює 8 годин на добу, а то й більше.
Робота - психологічно вкрай виснажлива.
Але він має свій рецепт розрядки.
Одна година спорту на день.
Або година бігу, або година силових вправ.
Війна на Донбасі для Себастіана- не перший подібний досвід.
Він колишній офіцер Бундесверу.
Має військову спеціальність розвідника.
Після кількох відряджень до Афганістану, вирішив змінити профіль.
Отримав освіту фахівця з гуманітарного
вирішення військових конфліктів і потрапив
до лав неозброєної спецмісії ОБСЄ на Донбасі.
"Я і в подальших місіях хотів би залишатися цивільним експертом,
ніяких військових місій.
Оскільки я переконаний, що дипломатичне вирішення конфліктів
більш ефективне й успішне, ніж лише військове".
Якби не спостерігачі ОБСЄ, жертв серед цивільного населення
було б набагато більше, переконаний Себастіан.
Якщо мандат місії подовжать ще на рік,
він хоче залишитися в Україні.
Адже поки сторони остаточно не припинять бойових дій,
вважає СВОЮ місію не виконаною.